what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today Chucky season two episode the rest
John how are you very excited sir how
are you doing well doing well I know
we're getting this one to you guys late
great apologies there's been a lot to
edit as of late and I know I'm falling
behind here but here we are and I'm
excited for it so please go ahead and
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also I just want to throw
something again uh one of the best ways
to support the channel is of course at
our patreon page where you get the
full-length watch alongs for many shows
but uh for Chucky as well and we cover
many shows over there exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch alongs
included but also to check out our our
apparel like if you're a true citizen of
the reject Nation you'll know nipple
chills is uh the go-to emotion when
something is truly amazing and uh yeah
we got a bunch of other stuff over there
as well
and I I keep saying and and thinking
like I got more to say come on let's
just watch the damn show ready let's go
I want you to choose the right path
but I'm not gonna wait long
okay
choose your final destination Jake
Lexi did you find anything out yet just
a bunch of weird selfies
the angles are all wrong
he looks like he's doing a good job and
a name my name
the colonel
Colonel Sanders must be the colonel
Chucky Colonel Angus why are you taking
pictures of us
oh no let's do it
[Laughter]
real torture
he's enjoying it I can't keep doing this
to kill me before he kills us look we
need to know he knows he's our best bet
on finding out what we're really up
against you know if you ever want to
prove the doll is real just cut him open
and bleed about it for everybody last
chance
how many of you are there sweet great
shot critics called this painting a
stunt Dolly intended us to do the
unthinkable
really get inside God's sorrow
his pain
his loss
it's a stunt
click bait yeah
when we're overcome with guilt we can
make ourselves sick
and if that's ever the case I'm always
here to talk
to Devon
to anyone
anyone who needs to pray the gay away
sometimes in order to forgive ourselves
first we have to forgive those who have
sinned against us
that's true forgive Chucky what I would
do is walk into that room where Chuck he
is secretly be recording on your phone
or his phone oh my God and then start
stabbing him while it's like life says
there's a lot of ways to prove he's real
he's been alive even if they're like you
could edit it how they have edited or
they don't have the time to do it you
know foreign
no don't do it you're gonna need it
that's what I tell all my friends who
are struggling
don't be a quitter
see this thing through
Alexandra
Ativan clonazepam
is say your mom's name on the bottle
if someone thought you were using or
you'd probably be stuck in here until
you turn 18.
just like me you know he's a good guy
man he's just looking out that's right
he's Good Samaritan this one you don't
have what it takes zero Killer Instinct
unlike the MVP of Serial murder shut up
I've killed more people than you have
insta followers and beefed with more
other slasher movies
[Music]
you think you can with me
killed your mother
hell I even killed my own mother
killed Nika's mother you killed a lot of
mothers I need to confess the confession
was closed for the day let's say 45
help it I have to go you are not a
servant of the Lord You're gonna send
this poor girl to hell what about my
sins I need to confess I need to do
penance
what about my soul
see you tomorrow Nadine you're a dead
priest oh he's gonna die in that
confessional I bet
look it's not in his DNA
if you wanted to talk you'd have to
completely be programmer wait wait
reprogram him
like brainwashing yeah do it do A
Clockwork Orange
how do we even know if he can be broken
but Chucky's taught me anything
so anyone can be broken
foreign
[Applause]
's tributing the thing lately
it's the popcorn
how are they brainwashing
I feel like they're only making it worse
these things
oh
oh like his dad
all this imagery back to back
is disturbing
[Music]
there's no way he called this aversion
the thought of violence is actually
making him sick now he's ready for stage
two
use your help here
horns no no no no no no no no
foreign
[Laughter]
ER Chuck
something's happening hey
I like to be hugged
hi
I'm Chucky
wanna play
how many Chuckies are there and what are
you planning I don't know
I don't know
boy I sure am sorry would this work
we didn't brainwash him we brain
bleached him well maybe he needs more
time that's Chucky and he's playing us
this whole thing is just an act
[Laughter]
who untied him
oh the ropes came loose during My Little
Pony
but I didn't want to bother anyone
I'm hungry oh it must be from all the
vomiting yep
only safe Chucky is when it's been
killed cut into pieces and burned I'm on
Devon's side if you keep him around
someone's gonna end up dead
so if we really changed it
what if he could help us
what if he kills you Jake what am I
supposed to do then you'd have to do it
every single day
for now
you want anything to track you okay
no
no
learn that if you want to survive in a
place like this you have to put your
faith in a higher power
on your higher power
oh okay
I own you now you think this place is
bad
how much worse it can get
kill them I don't know where you can get
condoms
Trevor cake
you bring your one testicle over here my
situation here couldn't possibly get
worse
[Music]
yeah
I'll ask and you shall receive
there's gonna be multiple Chuckies oh
yeah there's got to be more than enough
left
maybe it's just something I
produce a little or maybe the feeling
isn't biological
maybe it's more philosophical
nicely done guilt
it has a funny way of manifesting in US
I don't think so
I'm sure about that
come on May the chapel
if you want to live
here you go buddy
God even the way they do his posture
OMG
calm down Nadine he's cute and eats
though this is so crisp
[Music]
father Bryce said that if we don't have
the doll back on his desk by the end of
the day then there's going to be trouble
I only say that because I'm supposed to
stop getting in trouble father Bryce can
screw himself
I want to swear next
please Lexi look we're in this together
aren't we
okay fine just go away
thank you so much you're the best yeah
I'm aware
see you in an hour
it peek through
wait what are you doing
oh the price tends me to hard labor till
Chucky's return
what that's [ __ ]
you're telling me
guys are gonna burst into flames if you
stop not in the chapel
what's your favorite class nothing how
do you get your hair so shiny leave-in
conditioner
do you have a cat
absolutely not
do you have a boyfriend
oh
buried memory once
was he nice what was his name
whoa
Junior I like that name
where are you going
no no no no no no no no no no no no
damn it
Lexi's awesome but I think she's
addicted to drugs
actually I know it hey Dean and there's
this doll Chucky he's alive I don't know
how can a doll be alive the whole idea
kind of violates everything I believe in
right
yes right there it is
oh with the Rosary
and the Holy Ghost it's not that crazy
to think that there are other Spirits
who's hanging out
in dolls
right
[Music]
nothing like a good Rosary breaking shot
and nice Ruby beads
good standing for the blood so what's my
penance
ah 400 Hail Marys
you're the expert on Redemption
I am my child lives
400 Hail Marys she's gonna be here all
night pray for sinners
there's a reason she's addicted man you
gotta face this pain in order to
overcome your addiction which is not
something I would tell my friends
gotta go bigger say Medicaid more pills
is that your last one yeah she's been
milking this one pill those are the
pills she really needs that Rosary
Chucky
[Music]
bad bad bad great
did you know about Jake and Devin
what do you mean you know exactly what I
mean
do I
yes you do you can't do this without it
expect of the devil
my office we can talk about what's
bothering me there I have some
scriptures that are highlighted come on
don't do that Devin has done nothing
wrong he has nothing to do with this
our sins often hurt the people around us
more than they hurt us
that's true that's true John I know I'm
going to confession right now
I've been doing my best
all together because that's what's it
expected of me cool
chill
funny exceptionally good looking little
dressed Lexi
you think awful highly of yourself
your biggest fan I hate when Jake and
Devin fight
I hate that my mom can't just be normal
and I hate Trevor and his dumbass face
I hate that doll
which
I used to check those shower stalls I
know I can't really fix anything I can
be a friend and good friends can make it
through anything
you know just what to say I have a stash
of warriors in our room
and no one can be sad while eating Oreos
I don't really want to face the world
yet
that feeling
that's why I put up videos on the
internet
[Laughter]
you're alone in my castle of Solitude
that's not the same one
it's in your office and he's alive
leave it alone Mr Evans oh my God let
the priest die
Lexi Nadine
anyone in there
this pervo
forever like Sandra
oh my God I hope Lexi finds that before
she's ratted on so she could use them
thank you
what the hell just happened how
oh dang oh I never skip aren't they oh
my God we got ourselves a buff Chucky
buff Chuck
foreign
oh my god oh they're gonna blame the
wrong Chucky mother of Hail Mary Jesus
oh my God guys tell them report this
pricing Chucky was in his office he
walked out of her room killed Trevor and
went downstairs to keep [ __ ] with us
why was Trevor in here how do we know if
this was Chucky anyway
inspection
oh no inspection
oh God Percy's uniforms now inspections
come on no just just tell them tell them
there's no way they would suspect you
yeah his exploded his chest cavity
[Music]
oh thank God she could use it
do you think that flesh-eating diseases
are a real threat I really like jumping
in puddles but now all I can think about
is bacteria wanting to nibble me sister
Ruth I really need to know oh my gosh
what about bringing the amoebas
all good in here girls
so good at pushing people away I love it
use that I love it
wait where are you going away from this
what
Danny come on do you have out
you messed up Lexi I blame you for
everything Lexi it's all your fault
[Music]
Jake
oh
yes
[Music]
yes
oh those abs and you know I don't
usually eat cream puffs but today is a
cheat day
no
protect good Chucky
it all costs no I'm worried for good
Chucky I know I feel like good Chucky
can help us out good Chucky could be a
great series uh you know Ensemble
character what an unexpected turn of
events for how that all went down
last thing I expected was to have two
very different Chuckies by the end of
this episode you have soft sensitive
child Chucky and now you have super buff
Chuck yeah and uh I think it's cool to
get sort of a variety of Chuckies here
because while we've had like the
quantitative part of Chucky where the
seed has spread where there's so much
Chucky out there it's cool to get like a
couple of different ones in one episode
and I don't know how much variety we're
gonna be getting on them space Chucky
Cowboy Chuck yeah Asian Chucky
let's get all kinds of Chuckies in here
I think we should do it all but I think
that's a fun direction to take it I
wonder if it's something that
it whenever you do some type of radical
Choice like that which can be perceived
as a radical Choice it's the Chucky
franchise this series this the whole
franchise has been all kinds of Hills
it's had to go through yeah and this is
what I love about the franchise they do
something different they go for
something weird and different and I
think going for something like this is
is something you know I can be on board
with it I don't think it uh I can see a
scenario where someone might feel like
it I don't even care a venture why
people might be upset I like it I I
think it's cool no I do too especially
because like there's been such a
frequent uh motif of how many different
ways can we mangle Chucky and so I feel
like it's still within the character of
the show to go we had bald Chucky at the
beginning of this why not have a buff
Chucky especially if he does have
biological properties of some degree you
know yeah it just seems like the next
logical extension of that and then
you'll get even more fun combinations of
both what the Chucky itself looks like
and what it looks like when it
ultimately gets messed up and pulverize
yeah yeah so it makes sense I feel like
and as a fun you know this far into the
series you know Chucky's at a kid
there's Tiffany like I feel like having
a yeah some kind of left turn both in
personality and in physicality is a cool
you know fresh new Leaf to turn for a
franchise that's been going for so long
it says co-starring Jacob Breeden as
Chucky is there some fact I'm missing
my best guess would be that for certain
things you know throughout the franchise
when it's a Child movie yeah yeah for
certain things they'll have like an
actual actor if they need you know a
stunt or something that they really
can't puppet sometimes that that would
be my best guess unless it's
I don't think they did anybody else's
voice you know like spreador yeah and
it's just pitched down when he's buff so
yeah that's my best guess this is
probably just like a stunt stunt Chuck
that's cool that they give like the
puppeteers actual credit here as opposed
to just getting lost at the very end of
the credits because they're like they
are so much of what makes the character
and two especially in this episode like
it really did read in the mannerisms and
the body language and the facial
expressions and like there are there are
like multiple people controlling all of
those things at the same time to
orchestrate just one shot or one
expression or one motion or whatever it
is yeah and yeah when he changes over
after the brain bleaching brainwashing
he does have a whole different posture
and a whole different facial uh
expression array and yeah it's like it's
really beautiful and impressive even
though it is zany and kooky and all that
stuff well I'm glad they killed off
Trevor
horribly too yeah that was a surprise to
show the the lethal ruthinessness of
what this new Chucky can be but also
because Trevor is um it was like okay
here we go another new bully character
how how far my mind started trailing for
like five seconds of how far will he go
down this season you know with bullying
Chucky until he gets killed off in the
end I mean
yeah I I didn't know how far he would go
or was like Chucky gonna Mentor him or
take him out or some [ __ ] right yeah
so to kill him off like that I actually
thought was great and they subverted a
couple of expectations because while
it's done a couple of you know
predictable paths that you would expect
you know a young homosexual couple to go
to this Catholic boarding school you
would expect that eventually their
secrets will be caught by the head of
all of this but the way they handled it
I think is interesting like obviously
punishment would be dealt but as opposed
to like a bunch of maybe it'll come as
opposed to a bunch of preaching about
homosexuality being an Abomination it
seems like there's a bit of an odds here
because the priest played by
um Devon Sawa he what I like about his
performance is it feels like he's sort
of caught between trying to meet the
youth at times at where they're at in
modern day Society sometimes it feels
like he's he's there and trying to
influence old principles and not go all
out while you have that one nun who
teaches that like religious theological
class that uh
um that Jake's really drawn towards the
art class yeah our class yeah she she
feel he feels like he's very uh she
feels like very Progressive in like
modern day and more accepting and then
you have the other one uh the nurse last
Auto teacher who's
um like very old school about it all so
you have these different juxtapositions
that you're showing so I thought the way
they handled that was cool but then they
will subvert expectations in the way
some handlings will be done like I
didn't see Trevor's getting killed off I
didn't see Lexi actually on finding the
pills that Trevor planted there you know
and making some substance out of it and
uh yeah and I thought the I think it's
been a nice surprise when Nadine and um
and Lexi the relationship that's forming
like I thought that was a really nice to
have a good sincere moment in the
bathroom yeah that was a really lovely
scene like like that was another I like
when they
they're good so far from the first
season and then you know building upon
that with this season they're good at
surprising you with dramatic things or
yeah things
that do affect the story but aren't just
like oh here's a crazy killer oh here's
a crazy scare it's like yeah here's a an
actual they're really good at like
ringing the uneasy really sort of um I
don't know exactly what the right word
is but just those like little emotional
nuances is yeah Lexi does sort of
struggle but like take the opportunity
being offered to open up and to accept
at least you know the the love that
Nadine is at least trying to put out
there like I I just I love the writing
of that scene uh just that whole thing
about like yeah there's you know I know
there's probably nothing I can do but I
want to be here for you and I feel like
that's just a good articulation of that
anyway because it's hard to it can be
hard to consult somebody effectively
without you know doing a bunch of other
things that aren't actually going to
help and I thought that was Loveland two
on the opposite side like as much as a
lot of this episode had to do with Devin
being like I'm not cool with this
leaving the room and then going to you
know keep on doing his punishment and
stuff like that like that Exchange in
the stairwell they have where he's like
you know they have that uneasy Trust of
like Jake needing to see this through
with Chucky and to see where they can
get with this Chucky that they've
altered but also Devin saying like I'm
not cool with this and I can't go along
with it and I'll do the bare minimum of
you know helping you maintain this for
right now but I'm I don't agree with you
you know and I feel like there are a lot
of ways in which they could make their
relationship turn into some kind of
trite drama and thus far it hasn't and I
appreciate that too and even the choice
of having father Bryce clearly knowing
about clearly coming upon them in a
moment of intimacy and and you know
fully visually clarifying that for
himself and not you know immediately
making something out of it you can tell
it's on his mind you can tell that he is
working with you know that element as
well but you know the exchange between
him and the teacher and just getting
that as an expander on how everybody who
works here feels about each other and
how each other deals with the kids and
everything I thought those things every
time that seems like they could go to
some kind of trite conclusion I feel
like they'd choose something a little
more interesting and I appreciate that
yeah I appreciate it too I think I'm
starting to understand what they're
doing with putting them in a religious
Church Catholic setting because it's not
really so much about the religion it
seems I think you know Catholicism in
particular uh has a heavy association
with guilt and shame and living
individuals feeling that way you know
that term Catholic guilt today so if
you're not Catholic I'm sure you've
heard that before you're a fan of
Daredevil I'm sure you've heard it so uh
yeah you know and growing up Catholic
very much aware of the feelings of
Catholic guilt and you're dealing here
with characters who are
post-traumatic uh stress but you know so
much of that has guilt and shame that
comes with it and then and to put them
in a setting where literally just guilt
looms over you in the household of that
and it's sort of pulling it out of you
even more like that I think the setting
of where it's at is doing well
thematically to work with the characters
it doesn't really seem like it's so much
about the religion more about the
emotion of guilt and shame that they've
of course talked about a few times but
that's what's driving all these
characters down the directions that
they're going whether it's Devin fleeing
whether it's Jake becoming obsessive
about absolving where it's Lexi with the
drugs you know it's what the whole theme
with our main characters is is dealing
with so I think the setting is neat and
uh I thought there was a good little
brutal kill here and uh I I I I hope
good chucky sticks around and stays good
kind of refreshing to get like a good
Chucky in here yeah yeah it would like
it I it's I feel like in a situation
like this that can be a a tall order or
something like too cheesy but so far I I
really like that yeah I hope they can
maintain that and two we didn't get any
Tiffany we didn't get any Glenn or
Glenda so like we still have that kind
of
ongoing Cliffhanger from last time and I
kind of not that I don't enjoy seeing
them always I do or or that I won't
enjoy seeing Glenn and Glenda again but
yeah I liked that this one went
contained based off of how much there
was of them in the last episode not
every episode could be rings of power oh
we should be so lucky check him with
every plot line all right ladies and
gentlemen uh what did you think about
this episode of Chucky leave your
thoughts down below go ahead subscribe
click that Bell leave a like thank you
to all been supporting us and uh last
but not least let's end this with a
patreon
Chase Gardner Chase my friend uh you
have been here for a while now and I
wanted to say
you're welcome
I know that you being here has been
probably the greatest thing you could
have ever done and
I just want to say it takes us a lot of
hard work to keep you satisfied oh boy
frankly I'm always like well
I'm always expecting Chase to increase
his pledge of patreon and yet never does
and uh I as a humble human being go well
look how gracious we are for not
pressuring you to do so for letting you
stick around yeah letting you stick
around and still giving you time once a
month to acknowledge who you are as a
person
so you're welcome and uh frankly one day
I'm expecting you to give back as much
as we give to you yes definitely I think
we we wrote that until that day comes I
I will stay persistent in in hopes that
one day we'll be on this side saying
thank you but frankly you've given us
nothing to thank you for as of yet
you've done the bare minimum Chase so if
that uh I just think you know
step it up bud keep acknowledging you
every month
you haven't increased that pledge to 500
a month yet I mean uh you're so close
can you really call yourself a super
sexy reject if you're not
punching 500 a month which uh you know
comes out to roughly six thousand
dollars a year now that's sexy so I'm
just saying you know that six thousand
dollars can go to a lot of very
Necessary Things
you could finally fix the um exhaust in
my car
six thousand dollars that car cost
the whole car whole car six thousand
dollars very cheap car and it's
constantly falling apart so Chase come
on man help a brother out
anyway Chase as much as I like to end
there I I know that I I luck out
whenever I do a sarcastic mean shout out
so I just want to say thank you for uh
here disregard uh you're right you're a
good man you've been here for so long
dude
point of the bit is that is the exact
opposite that's the point
before you start yelling at me
that's the bit
you're welcome for explaining
[Music]